all right molly joining us now to
discuss this and other top stories let's
bring in our political panel
civil rights attorney leo terrell and
radio
show host richard fowler both are fox
news
contributors guys this may be the great
mass debate i want to pick up where
david swan left us at the white house
and that is
the uh timing of this about face if you
will
from the president from cdc that
first it wasn't okay because the science
wasn't complete but now
something has changed and you can take
your mask off leo
i'll start with you do you think this is
purely following the science or do you
think it's political
griff let's be very clear it's purely
politics a couple of weeks ago the cdc
director got chewed out had to change
her statement to give a personal opinion
two weeks ago the cdc director talked
about if you're going to have your kids
go to summer camp
uh you got to wear a mask all of a
sudden now it's been a complete change
and the reason why it's very simple you
got a border crisis at the border
you're familiar with that you're looking
at what's going on in the middle east in
a total chaotic white house and then
you've got javier pasera
running hhs who is a career politician
so it doesn't it doesn't surprise me he
got chewed out the bottom line is the
final point
is the school teachers a couple of weeks
ago on martha mccallum show they were
talking about holding back kids
and then on the same day she talks about
opening up all the schools
is strictly politics and a failure to
acknowledge the fact
but for donald trump we wouldn't even
have a vaccine richard
you agree
no in simple terms look here's what we
know we know that as more and more
americans get vaccinated every day
we can get closer and closer to this
herd immunity or the fact that we can
slow the spread of covert 19.
so what's happening every day is more
folks go to vaccination centers more
folks with their doctor
their local pharmacist and maybe get
back they become vaccinated
this allows us to move forward and begin
to roll slowly roll back
many of the regulations that were put in
place when this global pandemic started
that's killed almost 600
000 americans we are now at the point
that if you are vaccinated there's
enough of us vaccinated
that we can take our mask off both
inside and outside that doesn't take
away from the fact that many states
still have mass mandates in place
because in their communities in certain
zip codes cover 19 rates are to still
remain high and you still have to
operate with some level of vigilance to
protect those around you including
grandparents
including the folks who have immune
immune compromised including our
healthcare professionals this is a
multi-step approach and take us a lot of
steps to shut this government down
and shut this country down it's going to
take a lot of steps to reopen it and
this is what this is what we're seeing
right now griff we got to stop
we got to stop playing this game now all
richard said was generalized
talking points you cannot deny the facts
at the border you cannot deny the fact
that
13 red states florida and texas have
their states open
all the time their schools open all the
time don't play the
talking point this issue is too
important the situation in the middle
east
it didn't happen four years during the
trump administration schools have been
open in the red states
people are not working you got a a
inflation rate that's going sky high
talk about the facts
don't give us platitudes you cannot deny
the border issue griff's been down there
so richard if you're gonna go on this
fox news program
give us specific facts to tell me i'm
wrong tell me i'm wrong
facts richard yeah quick response can't
leave it without
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get in a
debate with leo about
him jumping all over the map and putting
together so very many of issues
the fact is the facts are negative
issues as more americans get better
ah i didn't interrupt you so don't
interrupt me thank you as more and more
americans get vaccinated we are moving
closer to being reopened as a government
right we're moving closer to going back
to what normal look like for this
pandemic but that's going to require
folks to get one or two shots if they're
taking not taking johnson and johnson
wait three weeks to be fully immune from
cover 19.
that's the facts no talking points all
right richard fallon
one point i got leo i got to let it go
we had so
that's a great debate to be continued on
another day thanks for taking time out
of your saturday have a great rest of
your saturday
we'll have more on this in a later day
we'll see where it goes molly